يندفع الجنرال إلى أي مدى لا يُصدق
أن هذا الصراع على السلطة بين
الجيش الروسي من جهة
وبريغوسيان وقواته من فاجنر قد تصاعد
هذا
الذئب البعيد ، وهو سؤال رائع وما هو
مدهش تعرفه في جميع
الجيوش التنظيمية لديك
شخصيات فريدة لدى البعض منهم الكثير.  من
الأنا أه كما ذكرت جيل للتو أه
ذكرت أه التقدم هو أنني سأقول
ليس مجرد قنبلة موقوتة ولكنه
إلكترون عائم في كل
مكان وما تتحدث عنه هو
التقدم وشويغو لا أحد
منهما محترف  الرجال العسكريون الذين
لم يكبروا في الجيش
يلعبون دورًا في هذا الأمر ، حيث أنهم
لم يُخضعوا قواتهم
لأمن روسيا ، فلديهم قوات
تم التعهد بها لهم ، إنه أمر غير اعتيادي
كنت أفكر فيه حيث كنت أشاهد
الفيلم بعضًا من  التي تعرضها
الآن الجنود الذين يسيرون
حولنا جزءًا من مجموعة فاغنر تحت
أوامر براغ ، ما الذي
يفكرون فيه الآن ، ما هي مهمتهم ،
ما هي مهمتهم بالتأكيد
ليست خدمة روسيا بل لخدمة هذه
الشخصية  والأنا خارج الرسم البياني ،
إنها نرجسية وبصدق ، هناك
الكثير من الخاسرين مما حدث
خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية سيكون هناك
خاسرون مستمرون وأعتقد أن
كل من بوتين شويهو واه براغوسيان خاسران
في هذه النتيجة
ما شهدناه خلال  يبدو أن الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
كانت أخطر
تهديد لسيطرة بوتين على السلطة منذ
عقود في هذه الساعة ونحن نعرف الكثير ولكن من
المهم أن نشير إلى أن هناك
الكثير غير معروف على سبيل المثال ماذا
سيكون مصير الرجل في
المقعد الخلفي لسيارة الدفع الرباعي هذه إذا حظي بهتافات
من قبل البعض حيث بدا وكأنه
يغادر روستوف على دون
بلدة جنوب روسيا ، احتلت قوته المرتزقة
هذا الفيديو بعد
ساعات فقط من قيامه بإلغاء
مرتزقته من دفعهم نحو
موسكو ووافق على ذلك.  صفقة توسطت فيها
روسيا البيضاء الحليف لروسيا ،
وبالتالي إدراك كامل
المسؤولية عن حقيقة أن
الدماء الروسية ستذرف من أحد الأطراف ،
ندير أعمدةنا ونترك في
الاتجاه المعاكس
للمعسكرات الميدانية وفقًا للخطة
وفقًا للخطة  قلنا أننا ما زلنا
لا نعرف حقًا ما كانت هذه الخطة أو
الآن تقول روسيا إن بيلاروسيا هي المكان الذي
يتجه إليه باغوسيان الآن ، لكن الكرملين
يقول أيضًا إنه لا يعرف أين هو
الآن ، كما شوهدت قوات فاجنر
تترك مواقعها من روسيا
مقر القيادة العسكرية في روستوف أون دون
زعموا أنهم استولوا ليس فقط على
هذا المقر ولكن
مواقع عسكرية أخرى في المدينة ومدينة
روسية ثانية بعد عبور الحدود
من أوكرانيا هنا فيديو جديد وهم
يغادرون [
تصفيق]
الناس وهم يهتفون واغنر فاغنر
مقاتل فاجنر  يبدو أنه يتم تشجيعه واحتضانه
من قبل السكان الآن في الكرملين
قائلين إن مرتزقة فاجنر هؤلاء سيعودون
إلى قواعدهم ويوقعون عقودًا
مع الجيش الروسي.
كانوا يستديرون